Putin's primary agenda they want to
change the global world order they don't
like the fact that America is the most
powerful country in the world and what
they claim they want is a multi-polar
world in other words a world in which
Russia China the United States are
equals that is not a stable construction
and they know it for well what they want
to put it simply is to throw America off
its pedestal Putin said in one of his
speeches at the end of Western hegemony
is inevitable you know I've been making
the point for many many years that
wokeness people think it's irrelevant
it's something that only happens online
and whatever but it's not I mean the
core of wokeness is the direct
destruction of Western self-confidence
the core of wilderness is to say we are
bad we are evil especially straight
white men but actually why women and
this and that and the whatever it's like
you're destroying your own immune system
the champion doesn't want to stand up in
the cage and fight someone else is going
to come along who wants that Bell